E aí
[Música]
e nesses poucos minutos eu tenho uma
tarefa muito importante te mostrar Por
que que um diploma não vai garantir uma
carreira de sucesso eu sou Camila Soares
Gonçalves advogada e professora ao longo
de todos os anos sempre fomos ensinados
sobre a importância de termos diplomas a
importância da titulação que nos falou
isso foram os nossos pais os professores
a própria sociedade e por muito tempo um
diploma foi o suficiente para garantir
uma carreira de sucesso no passado
existiam poucas faculdades e as pessoas
que faziam é conseguir um cortar as
faculdades eram pessoas privilegiadas
Então elas não precisavam se preocupar
com a concorrência bastava se formar
colocar um título na parede e isso já
seria o sinônimo de uma carreira de
sucesso mas o mundo mudou o mercado
mudou o perfil do Cliente mudou diante
disso vivemos várias revoluções
industriais em
a última que fez com que toda a
sociedade tivesse mudanças abruptas nós
tivemos Aqui estamos vivendo um momento
da hiperconexão uma sociedade totalmente
Inter conectada onde as informações
estão na palma da nossa mão a um clique
basta acessar qualquer buscador onde nós
teremos acesso a quaisquer informações
ela não mude todo mundo nós temos hoje
uma oferta de produtos e serviços nunca
antes imaginadas e está cada dia mais
difícil fazer com que tenhamos um
diferencial nesse mercado e muitas
perguntas podem surgir como vamos
destacar nesse mercado hoje altamente
competitivo Será que o diploma ele vai
ser o suficiente para eu ter uma
carreira de sucesso nós vivemos em e eu
escuto todos os dias pessoas
profissionais alunos perguntando
Exatamente isso mas professora como é
que eu vou me destacar nesse mercado
a área jurídica nós temos mais de 1
milhão 280 mil advogados Eu costumo até
brincar que é como se a gente saísse na
rua e tropeçasse e caísse em um advogado
a gente Sacode uma árvore cai outro
advogado e aí a gente fica completamente
perplexo diante dessa situação e muitos
começam a falar que o mercado está
saturado a saturação do mercado ela é
uma falácia não existe é saturação do
mercado o que existe são muitos
profissionais fazendo exatamente o mesmo
muitas pessoas agindo e seguindo o fluxo
seguindo a manada sem qualquer
diferencial sem saber mesmo porque estão
fazendo isso ou aquilo Manda fazer a
faculdade você faz mano fazer uma pós
graduação você faz também mestrado
doutorado vai mais uma vez e curta e aí
no Brasil nós temos aqui uma taxa de 25
por cento de desemprego entre Mestres
e enquanto o restante do mundo essa taxa
de dois por cento será então que diploma
vai ser uma garantia de carreira
certamente não então o que será que a
Mila Afinal o que que vai te garantir
uma carreira de sucesso hoje nesse
mercado tão competitivo eu te respondo o
que vai te garantir uma carreira de
sucesso hoje são exatamente as suas
habilidades pessoais inteligentes
emocionais as chamadas soft Skills para
você entender o que são as soft Skills
eu preciso explicar o que são as hard
Skills exatamente o oposto à tarde
Skills são conhecidas como as
habilidades técnicas que são normalmente
apreendidas exatamente por meio dos
títulos graduação pós-graduação mestrado
até mesmo pela própria repetição então
por exemplo um advogado quando ele
iniciou lá no curso de direito ele não
sabia fazer uma petição inicial Ele
desenvolveu uma vez duas 1050
e até que ele aprendeu a fazer uma
petição inicial isso é o tipo de
habilidade que é Técnica a hard Skill
essa habilidade no passado era
suficiente mas hoje 85 porcento do
sucesso profissional nas carreiras
Depende das habilidades pessoais de
acordo com o estudo internacional Então
nós vamos ter que desenvolver essas
habilidades pessoais inteligentes como
por exemplo inteligência emocional
a adaptabilidade comunicação negociação
vendas liderança resiliência E aí que
entra uma grande sacada porque os
profissionais que o mundo percebem que
precisam desenvolver as suas habilidades
pessoais eles começam a desenvolver as
crenças limitantes que podem impedi-los
de desenvolver como desculpas então por
exemplo eu não nasce com o talento ou
dom para comunicação uma soft Skill
então é melhor eu não ter que
desenvolvê-la as pessoas utilizam essas
crenças para justificar ausência de
determinação e de foco nesse objetivo a
grande verdade é Talento ou dom são
coisas totalmente diferentes de
habilidade não existe talento ou dom
para uma habilidade e as pessoas
utilizam essa
e depois porque é mais fácil e mais
fácil culpar o outro é mais fácil para o
mercado de trabalho é mais fácil culpar
a carreira que eu escolhi a profissão
que eu escolhi é mais fácil comprar meu
marido minha esposa meu filho é muito
mais fácil culpar os outros do que
assumir a responsabilidade pelas suas
escolhas e a partir do momento em que
você entende que a soft Skills essas
habilidades elas não são talento ou dom
você já deu um passo adiante e essa é a
primeira percepção quando você fala
assim eu não sei comunicar muitas
pessoas começam a valer se dessas
críticas né não sei comunicar não sei
falar em público não sei me expor não há
se com talento para isso eu não tenho
dom para essa característica só que como
eu disse são habilidades que podem ser
plenamente desenvolvidas ao longo da sua
vida basta que você Se dedique Se
comprometa tenha disciplina
e a partir do momento em que você fizer
essa escolha que é a principal tudo vai
ser mais fácil e aí nós chegamos à
seguinte questão mas então Camila o que
que eu vou fazer com meu diploma
significa que não é importante que eu
posso descartar o meu diploma já que ele
não vai me garantir uma carreira de
sucesso não evidente que não eu não
disse isso em nenhum momento A grande
questão é que as pessoas confiam no
Diploma como se ele fosse realmente o
diferencial como se ele fosse abre
portas no passado isso funcionou hoje
não mais então diploma ele vai ser o
primeiro degrau o diploma ele é o seu
primeiro passo ele é um arroz com feijão
o mínimo o básico é o que o mercado Já
te exige ele presta o põe que você já
tenha ele é um mínimo que você vai
garantir a sua obrigação depois que você
cumpriu com sua obrigação depois que
você se garantiu na sua titulação na sua
hard Skill aí sim você vai buscar o
E aí sim você vai desenvolver a sua soft
Skills que são as habilidades que vão te
destacar que vão fazer a diferença
dentro a multidão porque que algumas
pessoas têm carreira de sucesso e outras
não porque que algumas pessoas continuam
mesmo com todas as adversidades e outras
paralisam
é porque algumas chegam a e outras não
exatamente partindo dessa primeira
escolha da Escolha quanto a mudança de
mentalidade e de comportamento escolheu
mudar primeiro passo foi dado Agora
depende de você fazer diferente nós
jamais teremos resultados
extraordinários agindo de forma mediana
agindo de forma Medíocre quando eu tinha
13 anos como professor de matemática no
meu colégio me contou na verdade né ao
longo do durante uma aula e ele fez a
seguinte pergunta você quer ser medíocre
ou brilhante nos seus 13 anos
adolescente totalmente imatura aquilo
não fez nenhum sentido para mim mas eu
guardei aquela pergunta anos depois
cresci obtive de atuações e ainda assim
percebi que faltava algo a mais para que
eu pudesse me diferenciar e encontrei a
resposta
bom então se você quer obter resultados
extraordinários Age de forma
extraordinária então a mesma pergunta
que o meu professor me fez quando eu
tinha 13 anos hoje eu volto com essa
pergunta para vocês você quer ser
medíocre ou brilhante Muito obrigado